tu es un homme intéressant Scotland
tu es un Avenger
tu as une fille
mais tu as perdu beaucoup de temps comme
moi
nous pouvons arranger ça
qui êtes-vous
je suis celui qui peut offrir la seule
chose que tu désires
c'est à dire du temps
il peut réécrire l'existence même
floquer des flux temporelles
ne lui accorde aucune confiance
peu importe
trop de choses
grâce à lui on pourra avoir une seconde
chance
[Musique]
je vais faciliter ta décision
tu me rapporte ce que je veux
ou tout ce à quoi tu tiens disparaîtra
[Musique]
à ta place j'éviterai de regarder on
avait un accord
tu as cru pouvoir gagner
pas besoin
du moment qu'on perd tous les deux
pardonne-moi que si
[Musique]